in 2012 i told a story about the future
i don't like looking back at things i've
made in the past but in the last couple
of weeks i've had some emails saying
tom 10 years ago you tried to predict
2022 or at least some of the technology
in online world of 2022
you should look back and see if you were
right so i've come back to the same
place and i gave that talk back in
summer 2012 this was a warm friendly
temporary festival site with a load of
people on it and now it's a cold run
down deserted bit of scrub land next to
a motorway but it's the same place i did
originally try to film this without
having looked back at the talk to get my
actual genuine reaction uh and it was a
terrible video i'm bad at improvising
and i thought of a dozen more things i
wanted to say right afterwards so now
i've had some time to think
let's go back 10 years see what i got
right see what i got wrong
and see if i can predict 10 years from
now i've got a story for you it's set in
a future not necessarily the future i'm
not saying this is what will happen i
think that's the first time i ever used
that phrase it's a get out of jail free
card or wait to hedge my vets and say
i'm probably going to be wrong i use it
a lot when i write speculative fiction
april 2022 10 years time first person
we're going to meet there is jason
stewart he's the mp for tooting and
stretton uh he is the minister for
social development considered kind of a
hot shot among his party after winning
his seat in the 2020 general election a
very hard-fought contest all the
political guesses there were completely
wrong but then when has anyone ever been
able to predict politics also the faces
in this talk weren't originally blurred
i've used youtube's tools to go back and
blow them in the original as well
because there is a big difference
between asking a friend hey can i borrow
your headshot this talk i'm just given
to a few people and can i show that to
however many people will watch this new
video i've got a duty of care there this
is the 2022 iphone looks about the same
the laws of physics dictate you still
need a battery brick that's a hit it's a
very easy hit the borders of phone
screens are going to get smaller it's
not exactly a difficult prediction to
make and by sheer luck i used a black
background on the phone so you can't see
if there's a notch or not at the top uh
one subtle thing i got right there as
well apple did change the font back in
2012 they were using helvetica i picked
the wrong one to change to they use a
custom sans serif but i did predict the
ui was going to change a bit but what
has changed is the mobile network speed
5g now blankets the country in 100
megabit internet access and the data
caps are a thing of the past again a
fairly easy hit 4g was just being rolled
out in 2012 so taking a guess at 5g in
10 years wasn't that hard and actually
it was a bit pessimistic there are parts
of the uk where you can get gigabit
access on your phone now data caps are
still a thing on some contracts but as
far as i know they're not something most
people have to think too much about as
you watch this you've got to remember
that in 2012 we were almost exactly
halfway through the transition to
smartphones only about 50 of people had
moved from calls and texts only to what
we'd call a modern phone today suddenly
half the population was carrying a
camera all the time half the population
could easily cheat on pub quizzes things
were changing and they were changing
fast but we weren't in the smartphone
era social changes haven't swept in not
yet 2012 me is about to get to the
fundamental idea of the talk and it's
based on one of the big ideas that was
going round among technical people at
the time
life logging the quantified self the
plausible idea that we were going to
store all our memories online soon it
was mainstream enough that black
mirror's entire history of you had aired
just a few months earlier and now
everyone was getting a computer with
internet access in their pocket 2012 was
before google glass before the first
narrative clip all of which came and
went very quickly it turns out that so
far people just don't seem to like the
idea of remembering everything and
storing that data forever with
corporations this talk felt like a
warning but i didn't know no one knew if
it was a warning that was going to be
needed last year apple reused a
trademark and introduced ilife it's
quite similar to your history on
microsoft nokia phones or droid locker
on android they're all descendants of
the accountability systems that have
been used for police officers and care
workers for years now so many misses in
there apple have since switched to flat
design all the android services have
been rebranded as google and microsoft
nokia phones
and the idea of private contractor
body-worn cameras and that all sorts of
people all over the public and private
sectors would wear them every day as
part of their work
it just hasn't come true completely
wrong with ilife the phone is always
recording audio and sending it and your
location to a cloud server the
descendants of siri then generate a
transcript of it if you're talking to
someone else with ilife it'll give you a
text chat log it's not perfect but it's
close enough big miss companies just
haven't developed that people i think
don't want that but back then siri was a
few months old amazon's alexa would come
out a couple years later i'm sure any of
those companies could have developed
that product it's entirely possible
these days it's just that we went a
different way and if you have the new
apple headset it's got a couple of
cameras embedded in it which are always
recording video when they're connected
that's uploaded analyzed and stabilized
by the same systems the cable instantly
still gets tangled in knots every time
you put it in your bag that's another
big mess although to be fair to earlier
me i still think wireless headphones are
a terrible idea i can't understand why
anyone uses them uh they're expensive
they need recharging the battery
degrades over time they need a carrying
case they're easy to lose bluetooth is
still really dodgy 10 years later
i still use wired headsets now in
hindsight wired camera buds would
probably have drained too much battery
too quickly but i still think there's a
path that could have got us there by now
which brings us back to jason stewart
jason is a member of cheshire boys the
site for his old alumni public school
runs on disco a fairly popular community
framework that unfortunately has some
fairly major security flaws that's one
of the biggest misses in this whole talk
and it's subtle it took me a few times
watching this to realize just how badly
i got that wrong a community of school
alumni wouldn't be a website or forum
these days it wouldn't be independently
hosted there are still some places
online like that yes but depending on
demographics that would almost certainly
be a facebook group or a whatsapp thread
or a slack or discord server it would be
on some centralized service not a
private web server with off-the-shelf
code that whole business model that way
of operating was dying at the time and i
had not noticed i'm skipping over some
of the talk here uh basically that
member of parliament's password got
leaked
his password is stuart nine that's the
same password he uses everywhere and
someone goes hey let's log into his
icloud why is any of that on desktop
2012 was the start of the transition to
mobile first and i just didn't see it
coming all those screenshots should be
vertical on a phone i must have been
imagining people coming home and
checking this on their home computer
instead of getting notifications and
using an app on their device a couple of
years later that would be obvious
everything would start to be designed
mobile first but
in 2012 after i'd spent more than a
decade of writing websites on and for
desktop computers i just missed that
entirely that transition was starting
just starting
and i hadn't spotted it first thing they
see is apple's handy is this you feature
jason stewart can be seen in a few
frames of this walk by in shoreditch he
wasn't recording but his phone had his
location and facial recognition did the
rest and it didn't take too much effort
to find out what he was doing there
a few minutes later this poison pen
letter arrives in every single political
editor and bloggers inbox in the country
the sun eventually runs with it first
after all the blogs have made it public
knowledge blogging blogs were still a
big thing in the public consciousness in
2012 and i did not see their decline
coming i didn't see them being mostly
replaced by twitter should i have known
was it obvious it seems clear in
hindsight that the blogger spheres days
were numbered but i missed it about one
year after that talk google would switch
off google reader forever gaining a
reputation as a company that shuts down
old products instead of maintaining them
and it was all downhill from there he
decides he's going to go on the offense
he gets up in parliament and says that
our private lives should be private and
that we must investigate these hackers
and he convinces the met to investigate
which they do by filing a request with
apple for any life logs that mention
jason stewart in the hours and minutes
before the leak and apple agrees because
that argument got settled years ago
after blackpool
you can tell something about what a
culture is worried about or maybe what a
particular author is worried about by
reading their speculative fiction i just
finished uh the brief history of the
dead by kevin brockmeyer and there are
references in there to terrorist warning
beacons that everyone's got used to and
just ignores and as i read that i
thought ah this is a post-9 11 book and
it is it's from 2006 and this talk in
2012 still very much in the
consciousness of people working online
that we were one media-friendly
terrorist attack away from losing what
was left of our privacy rights your
lifelong will get pulled and searched
through by the police
it's not like you've got anything to
hide
right
maybe we still are it's just that as far
as i can tell from what i read science
fiction in the 2020s is more worried
about democratic backsliding and
misinformation and climate apocalypse
so there's one question left
what about 10 years from now what about
2032 i'm not immersed in web development
and technology anymore i don't code very
often i work on video now so
what can i predict well here's the guess
not the future just a future i think
short form video is going to do to
youtube what twitter did to blogs people
will still be making long form video
content it will still get linked to and
watched but short form is so much
simpler that there will be so much more
of it a tweet takes 10 seconds to write
requires no proof reading or punctuation
and can be amplified to the world in
minutes a blog post takes minutes or
hours to write needs spell checking and
formatting and takes time to be
discovered
it's not a perfect analogy but i have a
sinking feeling that short form video is
going to win just through sheer weight
of numbers the ability for almost anyone
to compete on the same easy low effort
low attention span playing field
but there's no money in it there's no
money in twitter just the ability to
promote other stuff there is still money
in long-form writing through commissions
or fan subscriptions on patreon or other
platforms
in the same way i don't think short form
video is going to kill youtube after all
youtube didn't kill television and
television didn't kill radio but
there's a transition happening just as
there was 10 years ago if you want a
prediction for 2032 it's that the boom
times for this platform for youtube will
be over
there's one problem with that though
youtube is centralized blogs couldn't
disappear because everyone hosted their
own in loads of different places often
for a monthly fee but youtube
well we'll have to see if in 10 years
time
google decided to shut down this old
product as well
you